this is my attorney mr. mr. dick licker
mr. mr. Zepeda me the Bucks corporations
thinks they're mr. Sirk opinion the
Bucks nitwit name of God do your duty as
you did the whole thing like everything
mr. Sukhram is it in your opinion no I
see it then should be me wrong sir wrong
Section 37b of the United States
Copyright Act of 1976 you'll school
fizzy lifting drinks the Box interesting
couple mutations here copy i the
undersigned shall forfeit all rights
privileges back you bumped his communion
37b of the United States Copyright Act
of 1976 it states quite clearly that it
states quite clearly that and you can
meet it in hate before now it's all
ganda you stole this man's junk you bump
duis in you bumped into his cute sooo
close then you fuck there now under
Section 37b of the United States
Copyright Act of 1976 it states quite
then signed by them again wrong sir
wrong under you the United standard you
decide he needs a stinky dick like it
well I said well so these sounds like we
have a very good case I knew there was
the wrong line but no ass we were doing
great